the insurrections led to trump's second
impeachment and trump lured up the only
lawyer missing from the dream team was
the cat right here they were trying to
did you hear me judge
i can hear you i think it's a filter
it is i don't know how to remove it i've
got my assistant here i don't know how
to remove it just can you hear me
it's something my kids put this damn
emoji on my face i don't know how to
move but uh that's not i'm not a cat he
said if you're alive i'm not a cat
he said
he said
i'm not a cat judge
i promise i'm not a cat i don't know how
to get it who the hell does
i don't know how to get this off the
computer church i'm not
but this is not a cat talking to
you forever
[Music]
one true hero that day capitol police
officer eugene goodman who led the mob
away from the senate chamber wrote a
don't you come on don't you come on boy
boy you see this little stick all right
every time i hit your head hey don't you
go further hey hey hey
get your ass back [ __ ]
see that was the smartest move he made
right there because it was political
people in that room and he knew he had
to determine to go this way
that was the smartest move right there
see that's he from the streets because
he knew how to psych them out they ain't
even pay attention to that room they
steady following him
that was a great great strategic move
yeah he better than me i would have got
him off my ass i was like that's what
you want you want the people in there go
that way
that's exactly what i did in fact i
think that clip would be way more
gangster if we reverse that look at him
now get your picture ass out of here
what would i say i got this stick crack
your head cuz your [ __ ] ass out
of here right now you back up boy [ __ ]
yeah
i got this don't even worry about what's
going on out here y'all just staying
there i got this [ __ ]
yeah yeah get on back in there and run
these [ __ ] out here
matter of fact i'm a backpacker and make
[ __ ] get out of here
[Laughter]
oh
yeah kiss my ass that's what i'm gonna
do everybody by the way that's one of
those moments where you really look
around and you got the feeling to go why
did i take this job like with all those
people sitting there you look and
realize you're the only one he's been
the only one there for years he's been
the only one here for years and it's
been the best job ever because nothing's
ever happened no on that day he was like
ain't this about a [ __ ]
where charles at charles he kept doing
it he kept doing this too pushing that
little thing but nobody will love him
nobody he got he kept doing this well i
said all right hey charles
hey josh what [ __ ] i'm matt mcdonald